[Music]
I'm maverick you're goose goose and
maverick needed a little more work or
okay Luke Bryan and Dierks Bentley that
was them last year still trying to get
their act down before they hosted the
ACM Awards together for the first time
and they must've done pretty well
because they got invited back to do it
again and we joined them in Nashville as
they were getting everybody excited for
the big show why do they pick us well
that's easy they are two of the hottest
and biggest selling country artists
today who happened to be good friends we
know too much about one another we can
kind of cut up with one another we don't
get a look we don't get our little egos
hurt yeah we're tough Dirk's has three
nominations and Luke is up for
Entertainer of the Year
this would be the third time he's taken
home the award he's won twice yes I have
but what would happen if there were an
envelope snafu like at the Oscars I just
love to have you know even my name my
name announced even if it was the wrong
name even if they had to run the back
door with it for three years Luke was
paired with Blake Shelton who had a
little trouble letting go off the
co-host spot last year
the fifty-second Academy of Country
Music Awards air April 2nd from las
vegas on CBS and it's gonna be a party
well it could be a very big night for
Keith Urban he is up for seven ACM
Awards more than anybody else including
Entertainer of the Year male vocalist of
the year and album of the year for
ripcord